Almost anyone knows how to play tic-tac-toe...
...but not everyone knows the strategy that guarantees they'll never lose another game.
You will need: an opponent, a pencil or pen and paper.
Step 1: Draw your tic-tac-toe board on a piece of paper using a pen or a pencil.
It should have nine squares total, with three at the top,...
...three in the middle, and three on the bottom.
Step 2: Whether you are flipping a coin or throwing dice,...
...you need to win the right to the first move if you don't want to lose the game.
Step 3: Mark the center square with an "X" or an "O".
This is the key to guaranteeing...
...you'll never lose in tic-tac-toe when you have the first move.
Following this rule will not guarantee you a win.
It will guarantee that, even against a tic-tac-toe master, you will never lose.
Step 4: After an opponent makes their mark,...
...look to see if there is a square to the right of it available.
If so, take it with your next move.
Step 5: If the square to the right isn't available,...
...take the square to the left with your next move.
Step 6: If the squares to the right and left are taken,...
...place your next mark above their last mark.
Step 7: If the squares to the right and left...
...and above your opponent's last move are taken,...
...choose the square below it.
Step 8: Repeat the right - left - above - and - below rule for each move you play.
Congratulations!
You may not win but you'll never be a loser.
Did you know?
In the movie "WarGames", war is averted when the computer is shown...
...that nuclear war, like tic-tac-toe, cannot be won.